allez hop cascades aller moussy sort le
grand jeu
depuis que je suis petit garçon je rêve
de faire du cinéma je rêve de faire de
jouer le héros dans des films d'action
c'est après avoir vu le film blood spot
mettant en vedette jean claude van damme
que le franco ontarien alain moussy a eu
le coup de foudre pour le cinéma et les
arts martiaux il avait 10 ans quand j'ai
vu d'autres gens tendance a été malade
écoute je n'ai jamais je n'avais jamais
vu un homme faire le grand écart
c'est vraiment quelque chose donc c'est
devenu mon obsession cette obsession lui
a permis d'accomplir son rêve il tient
le rôle principal dans les films de la
série kickboxer aux côtés de jean claude
van damme dray devant jean claude atsé
c'est assez incroyable pour moi parce
que c'était mon héros d'enfance voit
donc je me rappelle des sur le plateau
une journée on faisait il ya dans 88 en
incombe à l'eau dans la pluie s'est on
dirait que c'est le moment où est-ce que
trois matchs france le flanc à vous
allez moussy donne aussi la réplique à
mike tyson dans kick boxeur retaliation
il n'a pas pu s'empêcher de lui demander
le secret derrière ces opérations
jeanne bâtiment
malheureusement j'ai demandé quand tu
bouges est immense qui faisait ce que
disent les mots me frapper au corps puis
on peut casser ce son mouvement
donc j'ai demandé de m'expliquer comment
faire toutes les cascades des films
d'arts martiaux sont bien sûr
chorégraphié mais il ya une bonne dose
de vérité d'y aller mais aussi toutes
les coupes se voit encore son vrai
chaque fois que tu vois le mans tu ne me
lance édifié par la bauxite on au sol
c'est vrai quand même trempe une frappe
ça approche va par exemple il me suis
arraché si tu devrais je parle ton corps
se développent une cohérence quand tu
prends beaucoup d'impact sur ses pas
c'est gratuit
très progressif donc à mesure de faire
lancer comme ça en juger dessous je
pense que mon corps sommes vraiment
développer une tolérance à l'impact donc
déjà cessé mais ça c'est des années
d'entraînement pour ça et pour tenir le
coup le cascadeur n'a pas le choix
d'avoir un régime de vie spartiates
toute la nuit je mange très bien
jugeant le titre en 84 1% discipline 20%
plaisir c'est mon spi tous les jours ça
mais non quand j'arrive en préparation
tous les films là vraiment je transforme
tout je suis plus comme 95% discipline
5% plaisir même si un repas par semaine
que vraiment je me laisse aller à l'est
mais aussi à 36 en cascade
est ce qu'ils sont le poids des années
vraies réponses alémanique hammam et
autres
un peu mais j'essaie depuis pensez aux
accents cinq gardiens ici
louis philippe ouimet radio-canada mots
rien